a hastily arranged news conference
denounces the arrest of Rasheed ganoushi
he's one of the most vocal critics of
Tunisian president kais side ganushi's
inada party has joined forces with
others in opposition to call for his
release
is an intensification of the policy of
abuse and targeting of political
opponents and this is one of the many
stages that preceded it including
targeting activists and politicians his
daughter says the arrest is a political
Witch Hunt since the coup my father has
been interrogated nine times summoned
for interrogation for which he willingly
presented himself uh nine times for
frequently politically motivated and
fabricated childish
the arrest warrant accuses ganushi of
what it calls insightful statements he
was brought in for questioning while
police searched his home on the orders
of the public prosecutor
several senior opposition figures have
been arrested in recent weeks they
accused president Saeed of a coup after
he suspended parliament in 2021 and
moved to rule by decree before rewriting
the Constitution
81 year old Rasheed ganoushi had been in
Exile in the 1990s and returned during
the Tunisian revolution of 2011. since
then he's faced repeated rounds of a
Judicial questioning for party finances
and allegations of foreign terrorism
charges he and his supporters deny Imran
Khan Al Jazeera